ces nouvelles manifestations ce moment
en france contre le pass vaccinale à
paris notamment plusieurs cortèges ont
pris le départ celui des gilets jaunes
qui s'est rassemblée place de la
république un autre groupe de
manifestants est parti de la place
d'anvers dans le xviiie arrondissement
de paris direction place de la nation
pour les manifestants interrogés la
validation du pass vaccinale ne change
rien à leur détermination écouter
pourquoi c'est important faut continuer
en fait à se battre à lutter parce que
va vous avez l'allemagne l'angleterre à
l'espagne en fait qu'on enlevait la
restriction sanitaires alors l'allemagne
c'est encore un peu en déballant tout
cas l'angleterre et l'espagne ont levé
leur à la direction sanitaire et donc on
voit pas pourquoi en fin de compte la
france continue en fait il est imposant
impasse vaccinale qui portent atteinte
aux libertés publiques à la liberté de
travailler là l'idée de liberté de
circuler donc c'est complètement à
contre-courant de ce qui se fait en fait
au niveau de l'europe en ce moment
j'estime que c'est le pass and iter est
une violation grave de nos libertés
fondamentales
droit à disposer de son propre corps à
la liberté d'aller et venir
et d'autres encore donc je le tout nous
les remparts qui devait préserver nos
libertés le conseil d'état y conseil
constitutionnel se sont effondrés et se
sont ridiculisés les unes après les
autres donc il ne reste plus que le
peuple a montré qu'il envie de défendre
ses libertés fort heureusement j'espère
que le peuple va bien se manifester
comme il faudra dans son choix
aux élections présidentielles on nier
aujourd'hui on est sur un pass vaccinale
qui va comme l'a prévu magro emmerder un
maximum de français et pas que des noms
vacciner parce qu'il ya des vaccinés qui
vont se retrouver dans le carcan
aujourd'hui des noms vacciner parce
qu'ils n'ont pas fait leurs boosters et
vont se retrouver le bec dans l'eau et
ne vont pas pouvoir accéder à des
services à du cinéma des musées ou tout
autre chose en france c'est quand même
regrettable de voir un pays comme la
france mère patrie des droits de l'homme
qui aujourd'hui se couche devant abbasse
vaccinale simplement pour que certains
puissent prendre un café debout